all right Tyler didn't win but you are
America's favorite player how does it
feel it is the most surreal thing in the
world I honestly thought America did not
like me there was something in my head
telling me that but like it's a win to
be America's favorite player is truly a
win like to know America was behind me
like oh I played this game with
everything I had and just to know that
it's so crazy I feel so good you're
gonna go down as a BB legend how you
played this game I mean Julie Chen at
the beginning the season picked you to
win that's crazy I just learned that
that's nuts
the vote came down five to four yes
whose vote surprised you the most
mmm I really thought Bessie or Scotty
were gonna vote for me at least one of
them at least one of them fest he said
he voted for Casey because she got him
out you know I get that but I feel like
I just didn't do well enough at
explaining to them and I didn't do well
enough in my gbm's to get across all I
was doing in the game I felt like I knew
Bailey and rocks that were not gonna
vote for me I knew they were gonna vote
emotionally they had a great
relationship with Casey Casey played an
amazing game she deserves this win but I
I was really nervous about the votes
they kind of played out how I thought
they were good
when did you know it was going to Casey
was it while Julie was reading the keys
or was it before um when I saw the jury
nodding her head yes at everything Casey
was saying and then when I saw Betsy did
not vote for me I knew it was her I knew
it was her you got to kind of escape
some of the tough decisions at the end
yeah Casey had to say bye Angela Casey
picked the final two yes if it you've
got to pick the final two would you have
stayed true a final two I would have
picked case yes the difference between
I've been saying this the difference
between the final two I would Sam the
one with Brett the one with JC was that
those three came to me with that final
two I went to Casey on day one I went to
KITT Casey on day when I was gonna stay
true to that I was truly gonna pick
Casey yeah and you're walking away with
more than a check a couple checks you're
walking away with a girlfriend
I would had a girlfriend a long time in
but and we all got to watch you guys
exchange your first I love yous first
kiss is that weird to know that
everybody saw that weirdest thing in the
world to know that you guys saw that
it's super awkward but like best the
girl of my dreams man I couldn't contain
myself like oh are you moving out here I
heard her tell some people that uh maybe
she's got some room in her house she
could move in here she's got some room
and that's the plan I'm moving out here
for sure I can't stay away I cannot stay
away from her no so is she she's the one
I think so I never felt like that or
anybody so I can't believe yeah yeah you
just gotta have that house right there
trapped in there for almost 100 days and
now you're out here and people are
talking about all this business but you
were probably just thinking this is just
us right now I don't know what's going
on like this is sensory overload I don't
know dude like whatever life has in
store for me I'm ready for it but this
is crazy
what's the first thing you're gonna do
when they let you out those doors to me
oh go hang out with Angela because I got
separation anxiety RA has been like a
week and I'm already over it have you
guys been able to kiss yet yeah okay on
TV again giving the people what they
want apparently okay it's so awkward
visit I know this is these are
uncomfortable questions to be asked so
Angela at the beginning of the game she
laid low a lot do you know what the fans
called her at home was a color furniture
she was she was really a character on
the show until it was jury time so she's
they called her IKEA furniture yeah hey
man she got fourth place she was a power
player but she had a chill on it for a
bit I get it whatever I get you know you
got 75 grand a girl I'm gonna let you
out there in the real world
sweet would you come back and play again
are you need some time away I need some
time but I love this game I would do it
again absolutely I love this game I
cannot be happier with the outcome I
could have won but whatever like I would
definitely do it it was close you're
still a winner though I'm a winner like
Casey deserves
Casey deserves it like she got the jury
votes
Casey deserves the win I always say it
whoever won deserved it
because somehow they got it
[Music]
[Applause]